aaaah tráfego estou só o lado pessoal de
quem fala é o lugar que seja muito bem
vindo é mais um peregrino o jogo é toda
a bahia registrou o time e sei como
funciona como assim decidir os jogos
meu deus há muito tempo que eu não
jogava esta coisa nós estamos aqui para
jogar de visitante é o meu pc não
aguenta com este jogo que é isso é um
daqueles jogos que tive uma experiência
do rubrão vocês ficam mais lento e
apenas tem um tipo que ver o que dava
voltas à cabeça mar é que o bicho
japonesa já sabe ela vai entrar dentro
do meu quarto ela vai estar lá comigo
amaldiçoar enquanto tudo o que é preciso
fazer nada porque estava eu em um jogo
em que o sol se fosse isso que não têm
armas não tem nada bom vamos relaxar de
vice tânia pires que foi feito pelo xp
fã no longa e está no rito não está
entre falou ó kursk aí pato trabalho
mereceu uma voz meu deus meu o japão já
não tá muito obrigado pelo carinho mas a
encarnar jack uma coisa mexer em
qualquer coisa do gênero
o folheto rússia o seu domingo tem uma
sala acho que é uma sala de multi
polícia no quadro uma cruz junina parido
daqui a 15 dias todos no botafogo
o cartão 2007 alencar é basicamente só
tem rígido com vai acontecendo agora o
meu cu tá preparado no computador para
mim eu explodi do conselho tentasse
quatro em quatro com rocha cuidar rocha
coisa um quadro tem um cantor vai a isso
eu também pago olha só o meu deus ok ok
vamos gostar é que vamos ficar aqui
a roche nos importa
então qualquer coisa em cima daquilo que
não tem desde o camisa 1 em cima do
footecon trás nem nada é só a câmara tem
luz finalmente eu tenho algumas lutas
meu povo daquela loja cinema mas já
consigo
a meu ver alguém tá alguém do outro lado
da porta eo violência é possível estava
em silêncio e que não se olvida ver meu
não se ouve nada falou
quem quer ir mas eu tô ligado à guiné um
ano antes um só jesuíta ó não sei mas eu
acho que é justo mudar meu eu tentar
perceber onde é que isto vai eu não
estava sequer um set sequer vai perceber
que ainda importa nem vai perceber que
importa nem eu saí do be sentir o cheiro
é sinal do demônio não sei porque tanto
luxo forem que não há quase nada criou
designers entre os quatro é é não sei
que ainda preciso está tudo bem tudo o
lado pessoal porque eu sei como é que os
shoppings funcionam e os tios puxam a
nossa atenção para um lado e puxa para
isso bicho atrás nós do outro o orbitato
caso não se preocupe eu não morri ainda
é isso que eu brincar brincar no canto
a provisão acendeu e apagou muito
interessante é bastante interessar a
copa
vocês viram que eu eu não sei que estava
a pé e em 30 países
ainda que eu uso nem eu uso uma câmera
na perna
ainda não acabou ainda não acabou ainda
joga hoje aqui é um cisne é um fofo quem
gostou de uma câmera na perna o quadro
do seu mar ali à minha crónica vai
explodir e do solo calma você coloca
ae ela não sabe até quem fuja do óbvio
só então é isso só vamos ficar porque
com este vídeo espero que vocês tenham
estado já sabem enquanto o athletic
favorito fica em branco e de como se
vocês querem ver que mais preenche de
escola que ficou no canal que mais
aproxima